quiero hacer una pequeña aclaración del
vídeo de alcoholes en este vídeo y este
ejemplo de este alcohol de aquí y tiene
un triple enlace entre los carbonos 5 y
solo quiero aclarar que en la realidad
no se hubiera dibujado de esta manera
que de hecho fue un error dibujarlo de
esta manera la manera en la que debí
dibujarlo es esta de aquí y nota que la
única diferencia entre estos dos dibujos
si empezamos con el carbono uno el dos
el tres y todo se ve igual el cuarto
carbono unido al grupo hidroxilo todo se
ve igual y luego llegamos al quinto
carbono pero en lugar de doblar hacia
arriba esto se mantiene recto hasta el
sexto carbono y ahí es donde tenemos el
enlace triple entre los carbonos 5 y 6 y
luego otra vez vamos rectos al séptimo
carbono que está unido a los dos grupos
de bromo y luego llegamos al octavo
carbono y la razón de este cambio es
esta es la manera correcta
de dibujarlo la manera correcta de
dibujarlo es que los triples enlaces
este triple enlace de aquí
fuerza una configuración lineal por lo
que ambos lados de este triple enlace
irán derechos cada vez que veas
cualquier tipo de alc y no dibujado los
triples enlaces deberán de enderezar a
la molécula